foreign
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight up is a major breaking news as
the U.S Congress refers Donald Trump the
criminal prosecution over last year's
ride at the U.S Capitol it's the first
time in history that Congress is
recommending criminal charges against a
former president
here in the UK lives at risk as nurses
and ambulance workers strike over pain
with unions in the government at
loggerheads just who will fix Britain's
deadly crisis I'll talk to a union
leader
and as Harry and Megan return with
another toe curling trailer for another
Netflix series now they're demanding a
royal apology for all the claims they
made in the first watch of the palace
give them that apology or just banish
them
plus actress James Sheila Hancock has a
British developer lip is dead and the
public displays of emotion are now
fashionable is it time we all stop
crying like babies should we just get a
grip we'll debate that
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored
well good evening London welcome to
Piers Morgan on send sidmore on that
major breaking news from the America
Congress uh a little later in the
program of course they've just referred
Donald Trump for criminal prosecution
over the riots at the Capitol it's a
recommendation not yet a formal charge
but it's the first time in U.S history
that Congress has recommended a former
president be prosecuted it means that
Donald Trump might potentially be one
step closer to prison
but first tonight so the biggest story
in Britain tonight the strike's about to
rock the NHS it's one of UK's
Untouchable deities of course its staffy
the nurses are real angels but massive
industrial action by two sets of health
workers this week will test the
unconditional support to Breaking Point
falling ill Before Christmas is always
unfortunate this week is downright
dangerous nurses are striking again
tomorrow demanding a pay rise of 19.2
percent more than 10 000 ambulance
workers will also strike over pay on
Wednesday soldiers will provide the
emergency cover some pregnant women and
elderly nursing home residents will be
forced to use taxis this is a desperate
State of Affairs and the health
secretary Steve Barkley who's done next
to nothing to resolve this crisis but
he's right about one thing
it's the trade unions that need to
ensure that there is sufficient cover to
meet their obligations in terms of
life-threatening responses so those
emergency calls that are absolutely key
that we have sufficient cover in the
arrangements that are put in place with
each individual ambulance Trust well if
lives offend or even lost because of
these strikes public tolerance will
disintegrate health workers enjoy near
sacred levels of public support because
their work is a matter of life and death
of course patients are worried of course
they want nurses and ambulance workers
to show up it literally could cost lives
but they don't buy the government's
excuses either and this mother of a very
unwell three-year-old girl spoke for
many people when she confronted Mr
Barkley today
and the number of people coming through
the door is too many and it's not fair
to blame it on pandemic anymore is it
because actually we have problems in the
NHS before we went into the pandemic we
were sure to doctors we were short of
bed going into the pandemic so I think
it's really wrong to blame it on the
pandemic and actually the damage that
you're doing to to families like myself
is terrible
it's the mostly charged debate and those
emotions Cloud the facts unions say that
in 12 years of government the
conservatives have cut the NHS to shreds
in fact spending on NHS has grown from
130 billion to almost 200 billion during
those years but it's also true the
health service has been battered by a
global pandemic the demands of an aging
population and in my view massive over
middle management the government also
says that nurses pay demands are greedy
and unrealistic but the health
Foundation Think Tank tesl pay has
fallen by five percent in real terms
over the hardest period of living memory
of course they feel aggrieved ambulance
workers on the other hand say their pay
has also been cruelly cut but in fact
the same report shows it's gone up by 23
percent and eight percent increase in
real terms that makes the ambulance
workers strike to me you feel like a
dangerous and unjustified gamble
wielding our most vulnerable people as
bargaining chips
well this debate is too often reduce to
simplistic fairy tales of Good and Evil
saintly workers Scrooge government
Sinister unions it's happening on all
sides it does nothing to resolve an
increasingly dangerous dispute both the
unions and the government are doing an
emergency disservice to British patients
and the public and they have every right
to demand Better Lives depend on it
well I'm joined Now by Helen O'Connor a
former NHS nurse and strike organizer
for the GMB Union well welcome thank you
for coming in today thanks um for having
me on the show here's my problem with
this
and I'm going to read you something I
just read what I came in which was
really quite shocking uh when I read it
this is in the guardian which would
normally be you know very supportive I
think of a lot of your workers thousands
of patients who've had Strokes heart
attacks or broken bones will have to get
themselves to a e on Wednesday when
ambulance staff strike overpay NHS
bosses have warned the disruption has
been to the last up to three days
Hospital bosses have told the gun they
fail Wednesday stride by ambulance
personally Crossing and the wells will
entail a huge risk of harm including
older people left lying on the floor for
days with a broken hip getting
hypothermia and dying
only category 1 patients those are
immediate risk of dying for example
because they stop breathing will be sent
an ambulance during the 24-hour stoppage
with everyone else having to make other
arrangements
this is not a country I recognize that
we're going to let old people break
bones potentially face death if they
don't get treatment they may get other
infections or whatever at the busiest
time of the year when people are doing
this the weather conditions are
atrocious and have been
how do you morally justify doing it now
well it's a Health Service that I don't
recognize either appears to be quite
Frank when I first started in the NHS
everybody who came through the door of a
e was treated appropriately and what's
happened over the last few decades is
years of cuts in privatization to the
point where people are dying anyway
elderly people are lying on Floors
anyway even before these strikes so
things are in a dire strait stage they
have a hundred thousand but with respect
that wasn't my question I I completely
agree with you the NHS has been
absolutely on the Rocks now for many
years that's right and I hoped that in
the pandemic when the NHS Rose to this
extraordinary challenge so superbly and
we went out and clapped on Thursday
nights that real action would be done so
I have every sympathy with the state of
the service itself but my question was
very specific how do you morally justify
strike action which may mean that
elderly people who break bones in the
streets of this country don't get their
treatment because I don't think there's
any moral justification for doing that
it's one of the reasons the police don't
go straight we're not allowed to I don't
think nurses and particularly ambulance
workers whose paid let's be honest
comparative to nurses has performed
pretty well in the last 12 years or so
so health workers and ambulance Workers
are striking because they want to stand
up for the NHS their colleagues are
leaving in droves because pay has been
driven down through the floor you've got
trust setting up food banks for their
staff staff are struggling to cover
vacancies like I said to you already
there's a hundred thousand but again I
agree with all this right I get the
problem I get the gravity I get
conditions are awful I get the the lack
of morale I get the people leaving in
droves all of this absolutely is
inarguable nobody has more admiration or
empathy for the people that work in NHS
than me
but that wasn't my question my question
was notwithstanding all that how do you
morally justify what may now happen in
the next three days because I don't
think there's any justification for you
saying it's all terrible in the service
so what we're going to do is put even
more lives at risk well Pierce perhaps
he should ask whether the government can
morally justify the cuts and
privatization that have been making the
NHS extremely dangerous for patients how
can they morally justify the fact that
people are leaving health workers
they're going to food banks and existing
staff are just operating in grueling
conditions and those conditions are
extremely unsafe for patients you've got
patients dying prematurely in hospitals
because of lack of experience Staffing
because it's the experienced people are
actually leaving the NHS and what that
means is the more junior staff end up
having to step up and take on tasks
above their competency level so every
premature death you hear about in the
NHS you hear about babies dying Etc it's
all because of this stuff in crisis this
development I have a lot of sympathy
okay I have a lot of sympathy well I
should say a lot more sympathy for
nurses in this process than I do for
ambulance workers I think nurses in real
terms have seen their pay absolutely uh
be cut but according to the 2021 report
by the health Foundation the average
basic pay for ambulance workers doesn't
include overtime this increase over the
decade from
7580l by seven by seven thousand five
hundred eight pounds to 33 487 a rise of
23 in nominal terms eight percent in
real terms so can I just say to you
that's incorrect because ambulance pay
scales the Personnel are aligned to the
NHS agenda for change so their pay has
fallen as well their band five span
sixes so there's the whole Foundation
wrong these figures do not sound correct
to me well they are correct they're
aligned to a gender for change which is
the National Health Foundation Figures
were based on the prior decade and the
facts were there their facts
workers are aligned to exactly the same
pay scales as the nurse well the
ambulance workers their pay went up by
seven thousand five hundred eight pounds
to 33 000. 47 as an average pay doesn't
include overtime which is a rise I
consider 23 and in real terms because of
cost of living eight percent in real
terms that does not seem to me to be the
basis or justification for going out on
strike and potentially people losing
their lives so that so like I say to you
some of your workers okay I have more
empathy more sympathy I think some of
the nurses have been treated appallingly
but the ambulance workers who I I mean
again state that professionally I have
incredible respect for ambulance workers
I've had calls to years and myself for
my family in the last few years
brilliant brilliant people doing a
brilliant job it's the union leaders
that I'm holding accountable people like
yourself who are prepared to risk people
losing their lives old people losing
their lives potentially in the next
three days when I don't think that these
pay numbers for ambulance workers
justify so if I could answer some of
your points there yes first of all our
members would not be going on strike
unless they're unhappy I can't make
anyone everybody went on strike is
unhappy nobody would go to work no I'm
talking about there's always some reason
why people are fed up at work the Deep
crisis that's developed within the NHS
that's making them we talk specifically
about ambulance work well if I could
answer it don't talk about the images in
totality because I've already agreed
with you yeah but I'm talking about
ambulance workers they're part of NHS
they're vital staff their pay terms and
conditions have dropped to the floor
also the health Foundation actually
contradicts that it was a 2021 report so
when you say that there's a drop through
the floor that's not true in that
10-year period to 2021 they actually
went up by 23 and in real terms by eight
percent it hasn't dropped to the floor
the average hourly rate of the bulk of
these workers will be 14 pounds 21 Pence
an hour that's what they'll be on the
bulk of these workers they are
struggling so are you still in denial
are you still denying what the health
Foundation report said I don't I don't
recognize that you don't understand you
haven't read it I don't no I don't
recognize those figures because I know
have you read them I know that ambulance
workers are aligned to agenda this is
exactly did you read this 2021 report by
the health no I haven't read it
you haven't read the health Foundation
Rapport which revealed that over 10
years their pay went up by 23 you ever
read that and if their pay was so high
and things how do you know it's not true
we haven't read the report because we
speak to our members every Saturday
completely nuts how could you not read a
report by the health Foundation
members every single day of the week you
haven't read that report that's our job
I think that's kind of beside the point
it's beside the point to read a report
by the health Foundation into pay union
leaders cannot take members out on
strike unless there's serious problems
in those workplaces how would you know
there are serious problems on their page
you've never read the reports
why don't you read the report by the
health Foundation we can speak to our
members we know exactly what they're
you're not in the incredible the health
foundation so we know skills are we know
that pay in the NHS is plummeted are
they incredible the health Foundation
the reason can you answer my questions
are they credit
you said it was untrue then you admitted
you hadn't read it then you said you've
got your information about pay from your
workers and I come back to you I come
back to you this is a substantial report
into pay involving your workers by the
health Foundation it's a credible body
isn't it I'm going to repeat you again
because you don't seem to be hearing
this important point the ambulance
workers pay is aligned to NHS agenda for
change pay skills the bulk of people on
agenda for change are on band five which
is 14 pounds 21 an hour it is not high
paid as the average mean okay I hear you
yeah I hear you okay has the average
basic pay for ambulance workers
excluding overtime increased between
2011 and 2021 by 7 588 pounds so you're
saying they're lying so the health
Foundation is lying he has not why would
they lie today the RPI figures have come
out RPI is now at 14 sorry 15K right
sorry I was right in the face I was very
high you're talking about you're talking
about the two years or the year and a
half after this report this report was
2021 last year you haven't read this
report and yet you say their numbers are
wrong so I am telling you that I know
that the numbers
I'm going to repeat the facts again I'm
going to repeat again that you didn't
read this report so how do you know it's
untrue that our members pay in the
ambulance service is aligned to a gender
for change most of them repeatedly yeah
it's very difficult
of RPI being 14 you keep saying this
people are going to food banks I
understand you you're sounding like a
parrot now if you don't mind me saying
but the bottom line is you didn't read
this major report by the health
foundation and yet you believe it's
untrue so you understand how people
watching this are going hang on this is
a union representative who didn't read a
major report into the pay of her own
workers now deciding that is all a lie
despite not reading the report and
actually these numbers are correct I
think what your listeners would like to
hear about what they want is a bit of
credibility I think what they'd like to
know is how the situation is developed
within the NHS and why are our members
if actually because the ambulance
workers are on strike in the next three
days people die I think what we'd like
the government to do is come back to the
table how are you feel if they don't and
people die so people are dying anyway
more people I remember I understand but
if more people die yes if more people
die in the next three days specifically
because of the strikes by ambulance
workers how are you going to feel so the
question I'd put you is how's the
government no
but let me ask you again how are you
going to feel if people die specifically
because of the strikes in the next three
days nobody wants anyone to die but
people are dying because of the state of
the house
no no that's not what I'm saying but
that's the risk you're taking with
people's life and I tell you what if
these workers don't stand up for the NHS
many many hundreds of thousands more
will die because what will happen here's
what I suggest you do go and read the
report by the health Foundation it's a
good report and you're there you'll find
some information which might make you
rethink about whole other country at
around some of ambulance I'm not holding
the country to Ransom all right I
appreciate you coming in thank you very
much well still to come uh Harry and
Megan are back of course they are with a
new trailer for yet another Netflix
series apparently they're now invoking
the spirit of Nelson Mandela the other
famous man who sought freedom and the
demanding an apology for the claims they
made in their first Netflix series from
the royal because people they're accused
of being a bunch of callous racists
should they get that apology should the
world meet with them to give them that
apology that debate afterwards
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
what's up I'm Harry and Megan about the
new Netflix show and demand for Royal
apology over incendiary claims are made
in the first wanted to get one we'll
debate that a little later in the
program but first let's get more on this
major breaking news coming out of
America in the last few minutes the U.S
congressional committee investigating
last year's Capital riots on January 6th
has referred Donald Trump the former
president of the justice department for
criminal prosecution the charge is
recommended are obstruction of official
proceedings conspiracy to defraud the
United States conspiracy to make a full
statement and most crucially inciting
assisting aiding or comforting and
Insurrection now it's a recommendation
not yet a formal charge that will be
down to the video doj but it is the
first time in U.S history the Congress
has recommended a former president be
prosecuted and we talked now to U.S
attorney Eric Dr Eric uh what do you
make of this extraordinary news
I'm not necessarily shocked by it
because as the committee has set this up
with all their hearings they've taken
testimony they have shown clips of
depositions and sworn statements to
really build their case in the public
eye and for them to further put it into
into the doj's hands I do expect him to
be charged by the doj especially on the
conspiracy charges because conspiracies
are a lot easier to prove than any other
other direct charges because conspiracy
is only the part of the planning and
plotting to do something with other
people and they have sworn testimony
that that is what happened so Eric I'm
reading here this is from Mike Pence who
of course was Trump's former vice
president who said this just ahead of
the committee's referrals as before the
news was announced he said the following
I hope a justice department understands
the magnitude of the very idea of
indicting a former president of the
United States I think there will be a
terribly divisive in a country at a time
when the American people want to see us
heal at this time of year we're all
thinking about the most important things
in our lives our faith and our family
and my hope is the justice department
will think very carefully I mean there
is a point there that even if Trump is
guilty as hell as many people believe of
these charges and clearly uh Congress a
bipartisan uh committee here believes
that is the case or they wouldn't have
recommended it even if he is would it be
a good thing for America to prosecute
Donald Trump criminally and potentially
have him be put in jail
the the large the big answer is yes it
would be good for America because we
have to hold every single person
accountable for the things that they did
and Donald Trump who is likely part of
an Insurrection I believe he was part of
the Insurrection I believe that he went
forth and asked people to do these
things you it doesn't matter if you're
the smallest person on the totem pole or
the highest person on the totem pole you
should be held accountable and of course
we have the far-right extremists who
many of them showed up January 6 at the
Capitol and are part of this where they
were armed and have threatened violence
even after this incident so I anticipate
that side of the of the country to
really rise up some however my friends
he's trying to save basements he's about
to run for president so he wants
everyone to kind of stay glued together
so that he can get the Republican
nomination I mean when Richard Nixon was
convicted and clearly shamed and
disgraced and gave up office in the end
he was pardoned because that was
believed to be in America's better
National interest going forward than to
actually sling a president into prison
but again I come back to the Optics of
this I guess to the rest of the world
not never mind just internally for
America but if the DHA was to charge
Trump and he was to be convicted could
you really envisage a situation where he
is you know put behind bars with all the
impact that would have not just
domestically but internationally
uh I do believe it was it would be a
great idea and part of that peers is
Donald Trump was very vocal he was very
open and very public with all the things
that he did he had a Twitter account
with millions and millions of followers
spewing the hate spewing the different
rhetoric that led people to January 6th
and that is one thing that he needs to
be held accountable for even those
actions because if you are the sitting
president and you do this to your
country that loves democracy that tries
to force a marketing on other nations if
a person within our government is
against democracy then they have to be
charged if they're doing something such
as raising Insurrection against our
country
well Eric Guster I appreciate you
joining us with such late now this uh
much appreciated I'm sure it's a huge
story now breaking uh All Over America
and the consequences obviously are
enormous we could end up with the first
ever example of an American president
actually going to prison and that's a
remarkable thing particularly one who is
of course as divisive and popular and
unpopular equal doses as Donald Trump so
thank you to Eric uh for joining us
there well Harry and Megan have demanded
a royal apology for the claims made in
their Netflix documentary The six-hour
wineathon launched blistering attacks on
Britain and the British Monarchy and the
palace is reportedly baffled by the
request they're not the only ones and as
if we haven't suffered enough tonight
Netflix released a new trailer for
another Harry and Megan show this one
promises to be just as smug as the first
one
this was inspired by Nelson Mandela who
once said what counts in life is not the
mere fact that we have lived it is what
difference we have made to the lives of
others that will determine the
significance of the life we lead it's
about people who have made Brave choices
fight for Change and to become leaders
and giving inspiration to the rest of us
to live to lead
it's unbelievable isn't it I mean every
time I think they can't plummet new
depths these two they're now comparing
themselves to Nelson Mandela who spent
nearly 30 years in a six by six prison
cell
really it went on to become the first
black president for South Africa
a unifying leader of true greatness
one of the well actually the the most
impressive person I've ever interviewed
in my life they are comparing their dash
for freedom to a mansion in California
where they now Hawk out their Royal
titles for hundreds of millions of
dollars
foreign
that's what Mandela did in their eyes
well to me it's unbelievable but maybe
there are some out there that believe
this stuff
joining me now is the author and
activist Natalie Collins the former head
of Royal protection guy Davis and talk
to the contributor Esther Krakow well
let me stop the US you'd be waiting
patiently here
um they're the new Mandela yeah I just
find it the arrogance is incredible to
demand an apology because that's how you
get an apology by demanding one a
sincere and honest and open apology I I
just think you know they officially
declared war on the royal family by
coming out with this Netflix documentary
they made it clear that they wanted no
reconciliation because you wouldn't do
that you wouldn't put your family
through that if you really wanted right
open genuine conversation and
Reconciliation also they just called
Prince Charles A a lying bully yeah
they've called Prince William even worse
even worse so they drove him out of the
country uh with his or he drove them out
of the country with his bullying and
lies they've called the whole family a
bunch of races there's even one apology
from someone's people like that that are
so negative in your view well I think I
can understand why they're demanding
apology because they're so
self-righteous about everything they
assume they're right of everything I
can't understand what earth makes them
think Charles and William would even
consider being in the room with them
right now but I do think there's an
element of the longer that they can keep
this Feud going that's more money in
their bank account because now
everything they do they'll be oh what
about William how's your relationship
with the royal family how's your
relationship with your father and so
that's that's basically you know a giant
check that they've blank checked how
could you trust them not to just
basically record everything that goes on
if they did have a meeting like that let
me go to Natalie Collins Natalie I'm
aware there are people out there that
completely disagree and think that they
are true Freedom Fighters who were
oppressed by the royal family and have
taken their oppression now to this vast
mansion in Montecito in Santa Barbara
it's a beautiful place I've been down
for that area lovely rolling ocean waves
beautiful lifestyle and not my idea of
what oppression looks like but there we
are each to their own
um but let's get to this idea of an
apology that you can basically call a
family a bunch of callous races who
refuse to let you get help for suicidal
thoughts that you said you you said you
had that uh made racist comments
apparently that were so demeaning you
had to allude to them on an Oprah
Winfrey interview uh you now call them a
bunch of lying bullies including the new
king why would you expect anybody to sit
down with you and apologize after you've
done all the public trashing
I think in the context of a column that
was written today by Jeremy Clarkson
which uh described Meghan Markle as
worse than Rose Weston and calling on
people to have her script naked and
throw excrement on her in this tree I
think it's really important that we put
the context of and what Megan and Harry
are talking about in the context of The
Wider hatred which to be fair you were a
real Pioneer in that hatred of Meghan
Markle years ago I don't hate Megan
Marcus
you said I hate Meghan Markle let me be
clear I've never said I hate Meghan
Markle I don't hate Meghan Markle I hate
what she's done to the royal family and
to the monarchy and to the reputation of
Britain only tonight the New York Times
has carried a major op-ed piece
absolutely trashing this country as a
racist country with a racist institution
at the head of IT a callous institution
that should be dismantled so yeah I see
real damage in what Meghan Markle and
Harry have both down now to the
reputation of his country and to our
monarchy so yeah but I don't hate them
individually as people and if you know
in relation to the Clarkson column which
he's now issued a mere culpa over I
didn't think he should have uh put that
in the column for for my personal view
but he's now said he wishes he hadn't
either so you know I don't see what that
has to do with the wider picture of
these two trashing their families and
they're demanding an apology
well I think in the same way that you're
saying you don't personally hate them
but you are opposed to what they stand
for and what they're saying and how
they've behaved I think that's entirely
the same argument that um Megan and
Harry are making in their in their
documentary and in the work that they've
they've done is saying that actually the
way that they've been harmed by this
institution by this system which you
know we cannot deny the impact of
colonialism we cannot deny the impact of
this um monarchy in terms of we have a
history in this country of doing really
terrible things for the places and to
deny that reality to deny the impact and
and the reality this this month this
monarchy how is it that in this day and
age we have a group of people who were
born into wealth and privilege just
because of being born into it it is
absolutely they're also responsible for
developing that's the norm they're also
responsible for developing the
Commonwealth which has been one of the
great success stories in the world and
of course it's not really Commonwealth
though is it the people who've got that
wealth are mainly in uh the royal family
have a lot more
if you hate people who've got lots of
money without actually earning or
deserving it you must also hate
therefore the sussexes who've done
nothing to deserve it other than trash
well I just I
I think you know I I I think there's a
sense that of course people we we can't
like hate people because of their
privileged but they're what they're
doing with it or how they use a lot
utilizing it is really important as well
and I think there is a sense that we are
also talking about a a man who as a boy
his mother was killed by obeying mob in
the media and then was you know I'm
sorry I'm sorry again
these are easy lies to say on television
but I'm afraid I have to hold you to a
counter it's not a lie that is Princess
Diana was not killed by a Baby Alive
princess Diner was killed by a drunk
driver that was the official inquest
report into her death it was a drunk
driver speeding who killed Princess
Diana so it wasn't yeah
you might want it to be a bang mob and
maybe Harry has grown up thinking it was
a bae mob I could tell a hundred stories
about the way his mother colluded with
me as a newspaper editor with the
paparazzi or colluded with me over
having a private lunch at Kensington
Palace giving me loads of stories which
she knew I would then have as informed
information for my newspaper I could
tell the time that Diana rang me up and
gave me an hour-long interview about a
visit to a clinic she'd done signed off
on every page of the interview which was
faxed to her in return with her initials
on it and the next day said she was
outraged by the intrusive story in the
Daily Mirror which was the story she'd
given me at length over an hour on tape
so there are lots of different ways you
can skin this cat about the relationship
between the royal family and the media
my argument about about Megan and Harry
is they apparently were so disgusted by
this callous racist family and
institution that they fled the country
gave up Royal Duty now live in
California in extreme luxury and yet
bizarrely they still want to retain the
titles afforded them by the institution
that they describe as callous races and
they use those titles to make themselves
stinking rich without doing any work I
think that's hypocrisy let's go to die
Davies like the rest of the royal family
really well not really because they do
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
Duties a year well they turn up at 100
you know in three four hundred events a
year uh the main Royals so they actually
do put back that's the whole point of
the royal family they don't just get
paid for nothing they give back guy
Davis you were helping to run security
the royal family for many years what do
you make of this I mean I I read this
New York Times piece tonight with a real
sinking feeling in my heart that
actually the Relentless attacks by Megan
and Harry are beginning to really stick
in other parts of the world about our
country and about our monarchy
well good evening a very good friend of
mine defined ethical being ethical means
knowing what is right and Having the
courage to do what is right
as a former policeman what I haven't
seen one iota so far is evidence
and unfortunately people like Clarkson
give Greece to the story he doesn't
represent you he doesn't represent me
and he doesn't represent 99 of this
country I take great umbrage as being
classified quite often as a police
officer or an ex-police officer as
racist I resent it and I resent those
who have the audacity to actually come
out with this palpable nonsense with
little or no evidence the whole issue if
they gave that 100 million to charity
I'd have more respect but I don't think
they have no you know what day I get
called a racist all day long on social
media now as a direct result of Meghan
Markle Levering me out of my former job
in which she basically inferred if you
didn't believe her about everything you
must be a racist I don't have a racist
bone in my body nor have I ever said
anything racist about Meghan Markle no
one could find anything I've said and
yet it got so ridiculous even Sharon
Osbourne was fired from a job she loved
in America because she said I was
entitled to my opinion and for that she
was called a racist sympathizer this is
how mad it's got but this is the damage
that's done the royal family right now
in America are perceived by many people
to be callous racist without any as you
say die any actual evidence to support
any of these claims and you know I mean
die on a wider point where does this
leave the molecule what should they do I
mean the historic position of the
current family is you just don't respond
to this kind of thing but are we
reaching the point and I always think
that never complain never explain is a
good Mantra the queen queen mother's
mantra for being popular in the public
eye if you're a royal but I'll be
reaching a point where they need to
return some fire
well sometimes the royal family need
good advice their Protection Officer
quite often give good advice and they
listen
in this case I don't think they should
apologize I thought they were wrong in
respect of Lady Hussey in my opinion and
a lot of people disagree she had nothing
to apologize for I felt and I said it
either on your program or others they
were wrong to jump to conclusion without
hearing all the facts and actually
interviewing lady Hussey but we are
where we are now I just hope that
doesn't set a precedent because it would
be wrong and yes would I invite them to
the coronation certainly not from a
security point of view it would all
about them and unfortunately they have
caused as I've said in the telegraph
fairly recently in my opinion there are
Nutters out there who could cause harm
to not only the royal family but also
those in America the fixated threat
assessment of the FBI and CIA and I went
to Los Angeles years ago to discuss this
they are literally thousands in America
there doing nothing to support their
safety or their cause they are
completely their moral compass has gone
ski with them well I don't think I mean
look I don't think anyone so to anyone I
don't wish any harm on any of the people
involved in this Harry Megan any of the
royal family none of them absolutely
clearly they're going to get harm if
they carry on like this right yeah I
think all of it yeah I agree I think all
of it is incendiary and this book that's
coming out will be even more incentive
and poor even more people on the fire
but my question about the coronation
I've got to be honest why would two
people who despise the monarchy and
everything it stands for we think that
the royal family are a bunch of racists
why on Earth would they turn up at the
coronation
why would they I tell you why because
that's where the money is if they're
seen at the coronation next to all the
major Royal players that is gold dust
for their next Netflix series and
they're right there is the hypocrisy
that underpins everything these two do
gotta leave it there a good debate
Natalie thank you very much indeed die
thank you very much Esther you're
staying with us you'll be delighted to
hear uh well I'll talk after the break
about the modern obsession with emotion
which has turned us into a country of
cry babies British battle ax that's a
brother on kind well describing natural
treasure Christine Hamilton is here it's
a little to toughen up but Sheila
Hancock you said it first and Christine
agrees we'll be back after
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
this is talk TV
[Music]
what a lively old show tonight and well
good evening to Rod Stewart who's just
informing he's watching and enjoying
what we're doing tonight good evening Mr
Rod uh one of the great men in Britain
if any we were more like rod in fact
this brings me to our next segment as
the modern obsession with emotion turned
us into a nation of cry babies well here
with me are tonight's pack talk TV
contributor Esther crackers still with
me political journalist Avis and Tina
myself declared battle eggs I'm assured
author and broadcaster Christine
Hamilton I don't want to call you that
you burst into tears it would rather
kill the segment Christy this all comes
apart because Sheila Hancock said it's
become fashionable almost a badge of
honor to blub in public and there's a
difference I think qualitatively between
why people live people are at a funeral
of course they're going to be upset and
emotional I even understand great
sporting athletes when they put
everything into something of course we
get that that's not what she's talking
about she's talking about the general
run-of-the-mill kind of one radical
virtue signaling tears where Hancock was
a good example wasn't he when he cried
to me on Good Morning Britain about the
first vaccine and there were no tears
Christine he should he should have
spoken to Megan because she knows how to
produce well she boasted cheeky crying
three seconds I mean this this emotion
business it's gone full circle and it's
in Cycles it's like climate change
apparently back in the first Elizabethan
age the Italians who came here were
astonished at how emotional we were and
are coming from Italians that's pretty
rich then it all went completely back in
the other direction the Victorian age
and Empire etc etc and we all became
very stoic and the stiff upper lip etc
etc and then we had two world wars where
that was a very admirable virtue and we
wouldn't have got through them without
it then I think the the rot began in the
1960s when it was let it all hang out
you know and throw it all out there and
if you weren't emoting to everybody you
weren't feeling it well most of it was
down to drugs in the 60s right that's
why they're all blubbing but then the
floodgates really opened when we came to
to Diana gate and then everybody was
exploding with this incredible grief
which they were feeling for somebody
they'd never ever met I mean you I to me
you can't feel grief for somebody you
don't know I was very upset when the
queen died but I wouldn't call it green
I actually I did feel it too well so I
think you can finish the people who
don't exist I think you can for people
who are not family members but either
can I just finish that tiny Point that's
important against all that the queen who
was showing the traditional British
stiff upper lip was regarded as uncaring
and unfeeling because she wasn't emoting
all over the place yeah no you didn't I
didn't at all I don't know about that I
think I would actually say I would only
implore a stiff upper lip when it comes
to things like the queen dying I think
Sheila herself Sheila Hancock has come
out with this bizarre comment about us
somehow being softer than we were before
is the one who says she was crying when
the queen died that to me is quite
pathetic I actually think my generation
is a lot stronger than those that have
gone before
I would just like to say Christina I do
think it was slightly disingenuous to
say that we had a stiff upper lip during
the wars I mean in the first world war
after that we had awful PTSD and
actually you'd find men on the streets
crying and that is documented widely in
literature so I'm not so sure about your
account no but all I'm saying is that
this goes in this goes in secular Cycles
as it were and the the real floodgates
opened after Diana but it started in the
60s during the war if we were socially
acceptable isn't it I mean you did have
men crying in the streets but it wasn't
socially acceptable to just be out there
or mooting constantly I don't think it's
socially acceptable now I actually think
that's the reasons
and I would say it's my generation
because it's a very American attitude
it's very you know let it all hang out
explore your feelings get in touch with
your emotional side and it's so
inferiorating because I just think
that's a really good action there's
something remarkable about being stoic
and being and being able to hold it
together because sometimes you're a
source of strength for other people you
know what here's my overview I think
that there's no doubt encouraging people
to be more open is a good thing I've got
no problem with that I think that
there's no doubt that men in particular
perhaps felt a bit repressed they
weren't able to show I get all that
that's fine and I'm not against that at
all but I do think that when it comes to
the stiff upper lip it's become a stick
to beat people with that is somehow
offensive to have a step up bullet that
it's always a malevolent thing I don't
think it is I actually think if you're
able to control your emotions most of
the time and not just constantly cry
about things that's quite a good thing
too who has ever said that do you not
remember no every time I mention this
development honestly Twitter goes
berserk that's ridiculous people how
dare you you cried at Mount Margaret
Thatcher's funeral he was ridiculed and
rightly so because it was incredibly
embarrassing that that needed a stiff
upper lip I mean come on sorry who cried
at Margaret George Osborne oh wow I do
think it's a generation I'll tell you
it's a definitely generation the
absolute classic movie stiff up a little
was of course brief encounter with all
that repressed emotion one of the most
wonderful movies that's ever been made
if that was made now the Celia Johnson
character would have her kit off in the
station I just see you know what I think
here's what I think about this
generation being stronger I mean maybe
there are in some ways I think the
problem has become that if you actually
go the other way and you say right dust
yourself down get back up do the Old
Rocky Balboa it's not how often you get
knocked down it's how many times you get
back up and keep moving forward if you
can do that without blubbing all over
the place people now they criticize you
for having that attitude they think what
are you telling people to man up I'm
like what if I wanted a better phrase
there's no idea the abuse I get when I
say stuff like that but maybe man up is
not exactly the most appropriate I think
stiff upper lip is fine man up you're
essentially saying to a generation where
suicide rates are going through the roof
that their emotions aren't valid yeah
it's not about people who feel suicidal
it's about when you play sport for
instance at school I can remember all
the sports teachers like get up man up
get on with it I think with that right
it doesn't mean you're somehow weak it's
a bear in Fair individual it means get a
group of yourself and get back in and
I'm gonna get back into the second part
of this debate after break we're going
to bring in this whole debate uh Richie
sunac has told Gary Neville the football
Panda to stick to football after he uh
went on a rant on ITV during the World
Cup final uh about how yeah there are
problems in Qatar or what about the
problems here with all the strikes and
the government's attitude towards them
so should footballers stick to football
I've got three football experts waiting
to get stuck in this after the break
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
pack are still with me should
footballers stick to football uh friends
of mine like Gary and if you're very
vocal about lots of issues
um are they right to do that should they
just stick to what they do is it all
come to a head of course in the Qatar
World Cup Gary launched BBC's coverage
with a bit of a rant about qatar's
record on human rights Gary Neville at
ITV ended it with a rant not just about
uh Qatar but bringing in the UK's record
on strikes and so on at the moment which
made the front page of the daily mail
today is it just worth mentioning we've
got a current government in our country
who are demonizing rail workers
ambulance workers and Terror finally
nurses so in our country we've got to
look at workers rights and so on and so
on and so bringing in our record here on
rights as well and Rishi sunak said it
should stick to football well Pat what
do we think here Ava what do you think I
knew you'd go for me first
look I don't think think that politics
is The Preserve of the politicians I
don't understand why a football pundit
is not allowed to talk about I think
it's fundamentally undemocratic to claim
that he he can't use his platform for
that you know for what he said and
actually he made a really really valid
point which is that for some reason in
our country we don't think we need to
pay the nurses but we do look at Qatar
and we criticize their you know human
rights well I do agree about Western
hypocrisy I think one of the reasons
Gary uh Gary Neville and Gary lineker
both got criticized was they both worked
Gary and well both Gary for Bain Sports
in Qatar and taking their money but want
to go there for the World Cup and
criticize him they would argue well we
go there we shine a light and so on
other people think it's hypocritical
I'm happy you said that you know he made
a good point because I was just
wondering would you be against it if you
didn't make the point that you wanted
him to make this is the thing right
we're always happy I think that's the
bang on point you know we're happy to
say you know they're allowed to have
their opinions when they agree with you
but if you were saying actually you know
the government's negotiation with the
strike workers are just perfect Gary
lineker said all the things that people
on the right exactly they'd all love it
no but yeah most of our broadcasting is
what people on the right like I'm sorry
absolutely
come on lunatics on the left like you
here Christine well look I know
absolutely nothing about football but I
think there's a world of difference
between the two garage Gary lineker is
on BBC and he's paid for by the license
plate again never as I understand it is
on Sky ITV and Sky ITV and Skype that is
not funded by the public person that's
it's frankly it's up to them if they
don't mind him being involved that's a
very good point but as for the Qatar
business I mean it would have been if
he's making points about the evils of
the Qatar regime it would have been much
stronger if he'd made it in advance and
said I am not going I'm not taking that
I am not I also think by the way I went
to Qatar unlike most of the people
criticizing it I went to Qatar and it
was a brilliant experience that World
Cup I think you can have your issues
with some of their human rights issues
as I do but as a World Cup it was
fantastic and I would think we should be
more World Cups in the Middle East
frankly and we're going to take on moral
haloff in this country and stop tending
that somehow we are so morally pure only
we can hold 14 tournaments because
here's a Shot For You England we're not
we are slightly above Qatar in those
Stakes maybe but suppose at the Euro
final last year you wouldn't be saying
that nice to see you drew thank you very
much whatever you're up to tonight Keep
It Uncensored that's it from me good
night
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]